ça va oui or n'avaient rien à craindre
vous avez vu on a mis eric et ramzy
gendarmes ans pour me protéger de
moi-même quand vous étiez ici fin
septembre je vous ai demandé si vous
étiez nymphomane mais wayne et vous
m'avez répondu par période je peux faire
6 mois intenses et six mois rien du tout
vous êtes dans lequel six mois
je suis dans la période de réflexion
c'est à dire rien du tout
celle qui veut mais cas rien
c'est bon à savoir
alors j'ai demandé à la même époque si
vous étiez vibro et vous m'avez répondu
elle mange des fans août au but avait
dit que tu les étés les attaquerai pas
de tuer tout c'était un test pour voir
si vous
ces quelques jours voire six si vous
aviez un protégé de moelle et c'est
vachement bien
vous êtes vraiment sur le net donc
j'avais demandé à mes welsh il était
libre aux elle m'a dit qu'on m'a offert
un gode pour les 25 ans je m'étais at il
ajouté pourquoi mépris mais c'est dans
quelle rue tulle ajouté
et il a acheté non pas jo c'est parce
que si on m'avait dit ça vibre mal et ça
fait pas les bons mouvements alors
depuis octobre 2001 et jusqu'au 3
juillet vous êtes mewen au café de la
gare où vous interpréter un one woman
show autobiographique qui s'appelle le
pois chiche one man show voilà et la
reprise c'est le 5 août gros succès
excellent bouche à oreille tout paris
est allée le voir je crois qu'on peut le
dire tout le monde est assez rare
oui vous avez raison c'est bien j'ai vu
que c'est très très très très bien alain
delon était allé le voir
je pourrais y aller donc
ça veut dire que je peux le comprendre
que le loi
voilà donc alain de l'oriental et il a
dit à maïwenn c'est mon histoire que tu
racontes ma mère aussi voulait devenir
actrice vous avez ça en commun avec
alain delon me charmer iguane voilà
alors votre maire a trouvé le spectacle
d'une guerre pas vrai c'est ce qu'elle
dit ça c'est pas vrai elle a beaucoup
aimé spectacle m'a juste dit écoutez
quelques scènes qui sont un peu vulgaire
si tu veux jeter leur faire travailler
et votre père il a trouvé ça trop long
lui un nom ça aussi c'est pareil il m'a
dit je pensais pas que ça dure une heure
et demie je crois que sa durée 1h15
sympa du maroc mmm veut dire que sa
perle de sda comment ils peuvent se
prendre une heure et demie quand je me
suis pris 15 ans un
peu moins le chat non basée dans le soir
[Applaudissements]
ce soir tu as commencé
je soirée
c'est un grand moment de télévision
parce qu'il ne fait plus jamais eu ça
c'est vrai compréhensible c'est le chat
est devenu très très rares bons mais ils
viennent on va voir comment tout ça a
commencé donc un samedi soir vous êtes
dans les chiottes du fouquet's et vous
rencontrer luc besson et anne parillaud
et elle venait de recevoir son césar
vous êtes élu de les voir tous les deux
vous mettez à pleurer pleurer parce que
j'étais heureuse qu'elle ait son cv
voilà je me suis mis à pleurer parce que
j'ai dû goûter des deux noms
amarillo et luc besson vous donne la
main et combien de temps après il a
quitté anne parillaud pour vous dit tout
quitte à me parle pour moi non mais je
la tente comment vous êtes arrivé à ce
spectacle mais sur non pas par anne
parillaud et les voiles et l'a donc à
partir de là pendant six ans silence
radio on vous voit plus vous fait
dorloter par par besson à los angeles où
lui fait un enfant enfin plutôt à
hollywood et plus précisément encore à
beverly hills c'est la grande vie pour
vous faites des pâtes pour bjork pour
madonna pour sting vous tournez dans à
après la 68 avant la 70e du loret 73
alors vous allez me posais une question
les rôles sont inversés
est ce que
tu m'as vu chez fogel moment tu m'as
trouvé
[Applaudissements]
très bien
très bien il est gentil j'ai trouvé très
bien
tu faisais un peu peur j'ai l'impression
en
gt la fiche 69 alors là vous tournez
dans le cinquième élément mais quand le
film sort vous êtes déjà plus avec lui
puisqu'il est avec milla jovovich qui
est une amie de la maison qu'on salue
ici et vous rentrer à paris boulimie
total vous prenez 20 kg pas de boulot
personnes vous appelle vous dites je
décrocher le téléphone pour voir si la
sonnerie marché oui mais c'était une
époque où cheb pas du tout ce que je
voulais faire j'avais terminé une école
d'art à los angeles donc je rêvais à
paris sans savoir vraiment où elle est
donc là un jour un jour je donne un
cours de théâtre de ma propre me demande
de faire ma mère en impro et c'est là où
j'ai eu l'idée d'écrire le spectacle
alors votre maire c'est catherine
belkhodja comédienne et qui a reporté un
petit peu son ambition sur vous vous
étiez petite elle vous obliger à fait
reculer sa passion voilà déjà vers tous
les tous les castings vous envoyer dans
les castings avec une mini jupe à l'âge
de 12 ans ils ont pour un casting sexy
elle me conseille met une mini jupe mais
c'est pas non plus c'est pas idiot en
même temps
si cet enfant ce que vous racontez dans
le pois chiche donc le one man show donc
jusqu'au 3 juillet reprise le 5 août
finalement votre mère a gagné d'une
certaine façon est brutalement vous
soyez star fait de lui une star je suis
pas devenu une star mais je devais une
actrice c'est ce métier c'est pour elle
ouais donc elle a gagné bravo maman
est-ce qu'elle a eue récents votre mère
devons pousser
ses sons s'en rendra compte dans
quelques années et si elle vous n'avez
pas pousser vous seriez devenu quoi
franchement je ne sais pas manière ils
déclenchent après neuf coups francs moi
même j'ai pas compris leur père si votre
mère vous avez pas pousser ça que je
voulais dire
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux